[Musik]
herzlich kommt schon mal wieder leute
ich würde wieder vom staat mit einer
neuen folge von die strengsten eltern
der welt ich habe das video rausgesucht
was wirklich extrem knackig ist und was
wieder einmal die glorreiche und goldene
zukunft von deutschland beleuchtet weiß
es noch nicht wusste die strengsten der
welt in einer deutschen serie die sich
um deutsche teenager treten die extrem
aus der reihe tanzen sich einfach nur
geistes kann sich daneben benehmen und
in der heutigen folge geht es um zwei
brüder let's go
berlin teltow bei den halbbrüdern dustin
und jeffrey hängt der haut deshalb rede
ich möchte soweit eins zu eins so wie
ich und mein kleiner bruder also kenne
eine kleine aber wachsende auch mit kann
crafter und dicker
so war es bei uns auch immer nur dass er
nie gesagt hat sie an den pc
new york das ist ein bisserl hart zu
erzählen aber es war wirklich nett so
ich habe einfach immer gezockt und ich
war so ein kranker stück kommt mit
hobbys und wo ist da weiß dass max
einfach gar nicht versucht hat so zocken
hat einfach zugeschaut familie burkhard
dastehen und chef ray lassen ist mal
wieder ordentlich krachen bruder
die lachen ist ja so krass das gilt ja
wirklich auf keine kuhhaut haben sie
etwa haben die etwa gerade eine
diskussion darüber wer an den pc darf
unglaublich leute da dieses level an
gewalt an über griffigkeit in deutschen
haushalten in ganz kurzer theorie von
mir weil ich guck mal der auf der
rechten seite ist ja wahrscheinlich der
kleinere bruder der link ist der größere
also ständig frau ich bin der linke von
den beiden der rechte ist max sieht man
wenn du ich das oder sieht man bei dem
kleinen bruder dem rechten die ihr so
ein bisschen spaß auch daran hat seinen
großen bruder abzufackeln new york heute
kleine brüder seine geschwister
vielleicht vielleicht auch im eigenen
aber vor allem keine brüder wenn man
selbst ein großer es sind teilweise
echte richtig richtig fies
[Musik]
einfach mal eine klatsche ich hey leute
ich dachte eigentlich dass ich eine
folge die strengsten eltern der welt
heute angucke und euch dann am ende
sagen kann leute wir sind extrem
schockiert was heute gesehen haben wir
konnten uns in keinerlei aspekten mit
dem identifizieren was hier in dieser
folge passiert ist aber soweit flüchtig
komplett ab und fällt mit schiffen
seinem tor seine freundin ist da so du
willst seiner vollen dein pc zeigen es
ist keine ahnung was da ist und diese
videos 2003 du hast halt schon pc zu
hause deine freunde so marschall einfach
der heiße da kommt ein kleiner bruder
reindl abfangen jeffrey ist 15
sein halbbruder das stehen ein jahr
älter sowie zu dem thema kleiner bruder
scheinbar ist er ein halbes jahr älter
als andere dann vergesst einfach alles
was ich in den letzten drei minuten
gesagt habe danke schön aber man muss
sagen auch wenn er ist sollte er auf der
ältere sein er jetzt hier auch wenn ein
halbes jahr älter ist er hat diese
kleiner bruder energy checkt ja diese
kleine bruder energy so wollte so zu
provozieren und zu kitzeln bist du der
große bruder ausrastet die ständigen
auseinandersetzungen machen ihrer mutter
sehr zu schaffen
als ganz ehrlich ganz ehrlich an dem
punkt jetzt gerade an diesem punkt wo
ich jetzt auch die brüder hier sehe
hätte ich sie schon nach sibirien
geschickt es ist wirklich nicht mehr
auszuhalten sie haben zwei minuten
darüber diskutiert und ein bisschen
gerangelt darum wer den pc benutzen darf
ganz ehrlich ruf des sek ruft die gsg9
ruft die bundeswehr das geht so nicht
weiter
[Musik]
andererseits ich will nicht übertreiben
höchstwahrscheinlich gibt es schon
gründe genug das ziel dieser fersen sind
jetzt sind bei der es eben um schwer
erziehbare teenager geht jetzt habe ich
ja nicht gecheckt leute schaut da im
hintergrund einfach eine shisha einfach
einfach eine shisha und wie jeder mensch
weiß werden shisha wasserpfeifen dazu
genutzt um harte drogen konsumiert
gerade dazu ich habe halt früher einfach
nur so eine shisha geholt weil ich
dachte dann bin ich kraft also damit wir
nicht so gerne ich wollte wieso 14 oder
so und meine mutter kam wirklich
regelmäßig an und hatte mir unterstellt
da drin gras zu rauchen oder so
sebastian ich weiß jetzt was du mit
dieser schäfermeister ich so was du hast
darin marihuana familie burke hat lebte
in einem einfamilienhaus in berlin für
hausarbeiten sich jeffrey und da stehen
so gut wie nie einspannen
regelmäßige pflichten lehnen die
teenager kategorisch ab ja okay gut aber
sind dass nicht alle teenager der
pubertät so ich kann man auf mich selbst
wünschen ich war früher auf jeden fall
so ich hab keinen bock habt max war ein
bisschen besser vielleicht also mein
kleiner bruder max ein bisschen mehr im
haus ihrer schwester wieder mehr auf
mich ist wissen wir so anti egal das ist
doch normal
oder muss man die kinder deswegen jetzt
in die sahara schicken stiefvater andré
bekommt ständig zu spüren dass er nicht
der leibliche vater ist okay die
pressung verletzten ist halt moment
moment er erst 23 er ist 23 und ist der
stiefvater und autoritätsperson von
einem 16-jährigen zehner wenn der je 23
ist sag mal ganz ehrlich wie alt dass
dieser typ ich hätte gesagt safe 35 40
oder so aber wahrscheinlich 23 jahre
alte mal ganz im ernst er muss ich mich
wieder mit den jungs solidarisieren wenn
eure mutter wer die mutter ist doch mit
30 oder ja die mutter 37
dieser spruch du bist nicht mein vater
sie haben ja recht aber bei so ein
spruch den also zahl der persönlichen
und herz der zehner wenn du 23 bist also
ganze elf nicht dass wahrscheinlich fand
jetzt wenn ich ihm sage dass er aussieht
die mitte 30 23 aber die gal kann es mir
nicht erzählen um mal ganz ehrlich leute
also es gibt ja beziehung mit großen
altersunterschieden manche funktioniert
das auch wie auch immer will ich gar
nicht bewerten aber wenn eure mutter 37
ist ja ihr seid 16 oder 15 euro mutter
bringt einen freund an für 14 jahre
jünger ist als sie
und nur sieben jahre älter als ihr jetzt
sollen die brüder lernen dass sie ihr
verhalten ändern müssen
deshalb werden sie zehn tage bei einer
strengen gastfamilie in peru leben
new york new york es wurde auch wirklich
allerhöchste eisenbahn also was diese
beiden jungs abgezogen haben ist
verrückt und allerseits haben sich darum
gestritten wer am pc darf haben den
freund ihrer mutter der sieben jahre
älter ist als sie nicht als vollwertigen
vater anerkannt und was am sonntag
gemacht ja eigentlich nicht so viel ab
kommt schickt ihn nach südamerika egal
die jungs haben keine lust zu packen er
widmet sich lieber seiner freundin anja
wie jeden tag
ja okay okay aber leute es ist doch so
weit einfach normales menschliches
verhalten also im vergleich zu dem was
über die strengsten eltern der welt
schon gesehen haben in der welche kinder
gesehen die er vermutet krank sind
beleidigend martha also marschall
einfach die hübsche die ihrer mutter
sagt du bist hässlich oder irgendwie
schau dich mal an wie alt du bist so
aussagen allerdings manchmal sind aber
die beiden jungs aber so ja wir haben
halt mehr bock zu zocken und mit unserer
freundinnen oder unseren freundinnen zu
chillen als haushalt zu machen
und jetzt
du siehst du da bist aber ich muss
erstmal koffer packen freude kommt dann
erst mal noch mal leute ich kann das nur
noch mal betonen ich checke dass ich
werde mich genauso verhalten wie die
also ich will mich nicht genauso jetzt
scheint heute nicht ich wer du bist ja
mithelfen weil ich weiß was es
mittlerweile weiß mittlerweile was ist
was dazugehört im haushalt zu führen so
das ist schon auch wenn ich das sollte
mithelfen aber ganz ehrlich wenn ich
mich jetzt zurückdenken das alter so
schreibt es mit einem bruder so lasst
mich bitte jetzt kommt wohl auch mutter
hört sowieso ein bisschen lauter redete
und ist also ich schicke euch jetzt nach
nach china ja ganz normale deutsche
familie also es läuft wirklich alles
nach dem bilderbuch nach schema f vielen
dieser familie läuft alles perfekt ist
noch von dann irgendwie in dieser serie
auftaucht aber der stiefvater ist nur
sieben jahre älter als seine stiefsöhne
die söhne streiten sich einmal um einen
pc 45 minuten und werden nach südamerika
exportiert und die mutter sagt sie ihren
kindern dicker leute die große frage ist
was lernen wir aus dieser folge und da
kann ich euch wirklich die essenz hier
einmal ganz klar formulieren für alle
mütter da draußen oder mütter und väter
die es noch werden wollen gibt es einen
ganz kleinen grundsatz sobald sich in
ihrem haushalt andeutet dass irgendeine
kleinigkeit nicht gut läuft bitte
verband eure kinder ans andere ende der
welt den gibt's dann auch gar nicht mehr
so viel hinzuzufügen heute checkt hier
einfach ich vorgeschlagen das video
abarbeiten um ein kanal bleibt stabil
bleibt 23 mit einer 37 jahre alten
freundin macht's gut